people are increasingly Fed Up by the
accommodation um and the abusing of
Muslim minority and but more important
the culture that also destroy us because
this is the end of the day what Islam
will do it will destroy everything that
we stand for and the more we accommodate
them and the less we will get in return
I'm sure of that yes quite so uh I note
with interest as a matter of fact
that the next step is already happening
and and I I saw in the news this morning
that in Britain uh there is a
supermarket in a local area where
there's a large number of Muslims but
not a majority and they are demanding
that the uh local supermarket not sell
alcohol because they find it offensive
not to sell alcohol and this is
emblematic of the fact that Islamic law
applies to non-muslims and non-muslims
must submit to it in the classic Islamic
model such that uh it's not simply the
same kind of thing as uh Catholic Family
Law or uh Jewish law governing marriages
and so on that because it is expected
that non-muslims must ultimately bow to
it and I was wondering if that second
step after the uh first the requests for
accommodation of various particular
practices the second step of demanding
that non-muslims also uh adhere to
Islamic Norms has been reached in the
Netherlands or elsewhere in Europe yes
you it has it has fortunately in fact it
it's already implemented you were
talking about the UK we all know that a
few weeks ago it became public that they
even have Sharia codes today in the
United Kingdom can you imagine you would
have called me a total idiot if I would
predicted if I would have predicted that
two years ago that in the European
country the United Kingdom we would have
Sharia Cod and on the continent is are
there Al is there also Sharia being
applied there was there is not Sharia
being applied today but we had a Dutch
attorney general who said in a public
debate in Parliament I believe it was
two years ago that he could imagine that
if there would be would be more Muslims
in the Netherlands that if there if
there would be at the end of the day
majority of Muslims that the Sharia
would be implemented in the Netherlands
in in in in what he should have said is
that I will make sure that a never our
country will consist out of 50% of
Muslims but B even if that would happen
that we would do everything to prevent
the sh implemented because means and of
democracy Sharia means end of Freedom
sham means submission to the most
terrible Islamic Islamic uh law so um
you see that indeed happening uh those
kind of Demands uh in Europe and in the
Netherlands slowly the political Elite
is giving in but and this is the good
news the public the electorate is
increasingly Fed Up by accommodating um
um um Muslims in the way they want to so
the countervailing power against the
weak deud of the political Elite is
increasingly strong so you see the UK as
a kind of a European Vanguard in its
adoption of sharia and you think that
Continental Europe will follow yes I'm
afraid so that's why I was very
impressed by I I met this week here in
United States Congressman P tanko yes
and I was very much impressed that he
made as you say unfortunately he's
leaving office soon but he made this
anti- Jihad law and he said well if if
if somebody who is resident of the
United States is in favor of sharia we
we should be able to extra them and
somebody who comes to the United States
and is a favor of sharia should not be
permitted I mean this is a first step I
would wish that um um um European
leaders Robert we are um without we have
a problem in Europe that we are we have
no real leaders in more there is a lack
of leadership in Europe people who lead
their country with they are all
accommodating they are all looking for
political economical political correct
reasons wanting to be in office the day
after tomorrow but they are forgetting
that we are losing our continent we are
losing our identity we are losing
everything that we stand for and this is
leadership that you stand up and that
you say whatever the consequences this
um um may not and shall not uh ever uh
happen and unfortunately that is lacking
in Europe today do you think that in the
the coming years that there will be a
growing movement in Europe against
islamization and that the mainstream
parties will take it up well you you I
if I talk about my country the
Netherlands you already see that we are
not only almost doubling in the PO since
one and a half year but you see that the
the the parties that we are getting
voters from uh very slowly changing
their tune not perhaps because they
really believe in what I say but because
this is politics they don't like they
want their voters back so very slowly it
might happen but it it will be it will
be too late before anything change
that's why I'm I'm very proud and very
happy that there will be an initiative
in Jerusalem in December of this year um
hosted by Professor Alat a member of CET
in the in the in in Israeli Parliament
and there um 10 20 30 um um European
lawmakers from respected countries where
there is a grow of that kind of parties
like my party like for instance the
Danish people party that they would come
there and not only talk about how bad it
is today in Europe but also try to come
with Concrete Solutions when it comes to
immigration when it comes to um
initiatives initial law to ban the
Sharia forever I mean be concrete and
and and show the people not only that we
have Solutions and that we are serious
politicians but also show the electorate
that there is not only in some country
one or two mjor that are labeled by the
leftish liberal Elite and press as as
xenophobes no but that we are
responsible politicians and not racist
and nothing whatsoever and that we have
initiatives and that we are combining
our forces and this is not only a
message to the electorat and to the
leftish and liberal press and Elite in
Europe but it's also a message to the
Arab world and to the Islamic world and
to the people already in Europe from
back it's a message that there are not
only there are not only deis in Europe
there are also people who are willing to
fight in a democratic way in a
nonviolent way but we will fight you and
we will startop now and we will never
stop and we are aware of what the
program is we're aware of what they're
trying to do exactly when the mainstream
is still completely clueless about this
you're fully right excellent excellent
well that sounds like a very important
conference and I wish you all success in
that I hope you will be there I hope so
yes indeed we'll be great yes uh in any
case do you see then the future of
Europe as uh one in which
anti-islamic uh anti- islamization
groups might actually become a
majority well a lot of things have to
happen I was a guest in Switzerland not
so long ago of when in B and and her
husband and you know she wrote this
important book uraban yes and uh I
remember when I first read
it like I read with all the pleasure all
your books as well and I learned a lot I
learned a lot from it really that um
when you read it at the first time you
think well it's it's it's maybe in the
future it will happen but it's it's
coming it's coming uh very very close
and um we are very far away today for
the anti- islamization organizations to
become majority but we are gaining voter
by voter person by person day by day uh
we are gaining uh uh Grant we are we are
winning uh um very slowly but we are
winning and um this is is is so
important so it will not be in a couple
of years time perhaps but it also
depends what the elite what the ruling
demies of the elite will do will they
change their tune or will they not
because like I told you in many many
countries the um the gap between the
political Elite and the fox popular is
is is is very very large and um if that
bridge will not be um will not be
crossed then uh I think um um it will be
sooner that there would come a majority
of people who fight against it